y ya quemaron.
En ese tiempo, ¿cómo se mantenía usted?
Desde el 39 hasta el 41.
Yo quiero decir, como yo tengo ese profesor,
que hay muchas mercancías, se vendían, y así, y así.
Además de hacer esas acciones con los judíos,
¿les hacían otras cosas?
¿No podían trabajar públicamente?
¿Qué otras leyes?
No, todo, todo liquidado.
Todos los negocios liquidados
ya no tienen derecho para nada.
Y puso, mira, un alemán, se llama Falkenberg.
Tenía dos mil personas judías para trabajo
y siempre yo en el día veía el pan.
Yo todavía no trabajaba y nadie me habló.
Nadie.
El suegro estaba en mi casa,
mi madre en mi casa, mi suegro en mi casa,
y yo sabía cómo trabajaba en la casa.
Ahorita está pasando otra historia.
Otra historia.
¿Cuál la historia?
Este señor
viene de Dublín con un, con esto,
full con dinero polaco, con slot
y con permiso de, para export, tablas
para Dublín, para alemanes.
Conocía ya, mira, yo no sé cómo era,
no te puedo explicar.
Él me explicó, mira, se conocía, mira,
así, así, así, así.
Y llegó a mi casa con todo eso.
Mira cómo lo pudo lograr.
Era un seredero, se llamaba Helmut Bloch,
un gran seredero.
Era de Javier Zaborizky,
pero como era alemán, quitaron eso.
El vector de este seredero
era Lehmann Schick, un focos de alemán.
Miedo.
Era todo, con entrar allá, mira,
como usted me diga, señor,
ay, se va a matar para cielo.
Así era entrar allá.
Usted ve, mira, a mí,
yo dejó al señor esperando allá,
mi casa, y me fui, no conocía a ese
Lehmann Schick, vector,
era un italiano más grande que Caracas.
Y difícilmente, yo estoy llegando a la oficina de él.
¿En dónde?
En Vlodava, en la oficina de Helmut Bloch,
era director, él manejaba con todo.
Me presentó el señor Rice,
y me dice, polaco,
¿cómo te entraste?
No sé, me dejaron entrar.
Él, no sé yo, dice,
God, my God,
¿cómo te entraste?
¿Cómo te dejaron entrar?
Él no entendió.
Siéntese.
Necesito un poquito de agua.
Toma.
¿Qué tú vas a decir?
Yo, en porcillo, puso dos premisas para tablas.
Dice, un polaco,
vino un señor, que me trajo premisas,
filmado en alemán,
que necesitan, ellos tienen el dinero,
premisas de toro,
que hago export para Lublin,
con tren.
¿Y tú no tienes miedo?
Mira, es nunca que tengo miedo de Dios.
God, my God.
En alemán, él.
Habla bien polaco.
God, my God.
¿Qué tú quieres hacer?
Yo quiero comprar cien metros
tablas.
¿Y tiene dinero para pagar?
No hay dinero para pagar.
Se levanta,
en el tamaño más bajo que este señor,
y hace un paseo por aquí.
Siéntese.
Yo digo, un polaco, él.
Muere bien.
Yo soy comerciante de nuevo a ellos,
en alemán.
Yo soy hombre que me gusta vivir y dejar de vivir.
¿Usted me entiende?
De tonto, él no tenía nada.
Él tenía muy bien.
Y se puso nariz abajo de nariz.
Inmediatamente,
me dio una carta
que yo trabajo para Edmund Bloch.
¿Eso fue en qué año?
¿Ah?
En el año cuarenta y uno.
Antes, una interrupción pequeña.
¿Usted usaba Estrella de David?
¿Habían prohibiciones además de trabajar para los judíos?
¿Desde cuándo fue eso?
¿Qué otra cosa pasó con los judíos?
No.
En otra parte, en Polonia,
dijeron, yo no la vi,
que pusieron mugendovet amarillo en la espalda.
En Ciudad de los Otros, era puro.
Diez centímetros de ancho.
¿En qué mano?
Blanco, mano izquierda.
¿Y las escuelas seguían?
¿Las escuelas judías?
¿Dónde las escuelas?
No hay escuelas.
Ya todo...
Nada.
Cada uno temblando,
escondido, mire,
para no llevar para...
Oye, vamos a ir con la historia.
Para saber qué está pasando.
Entonces ya yo tengo
una carta,
que tengo derecho a salir y entrar.
Sin miedo.
Yo hice la compra.
Ya podía venir con monetín, con dinero.
Pagó.
Y tengo que reconocer,
pagó una gran parte.
Él también me recibió.
Y ya acogió
confianza y cariño a mí.
Cuando usted dice salir y entrar,
¿salir y entrar de dónde?
Para oficina
de Elmwood Block,
como yo estoy diciendo,
para oficina de él.
Ese era
como un kilómetro de ciudad.
Fue un gran terreno,
cerradera,
con tablas, mire,
una cosa muy, muy, muy, muy, muy grande.
Vamos a descansar un poquitito.
¿Entonces?
Allá, mire, empezó
y este hombre
cada vez me trajo más dinero,
más permisos,
y hizo un negocio
en escala grande.
¿Y qué pasaba con la comunidad judía?
¿Seguían enviando gente a Sobibor?
Trabajaban, mire,
y se quedaban para el crematorio.
Es mucho accionista.
Lo que tenía
un permiso, como yo tenía,
o otro más,
era más de otras clases,
dejaron de momento.
¿Usted seguía viviendo en su misma casa?
En mi misma casa,
junto con mi mamá,
con todo.
¿Qué está pasando?
Un sábado en la mañana
un grito, alarma, ansiedad,
que están despertando todos los judíos.
Y yo estoy en mi casa.
Primero yo agarré a mi señora
al lado de un señor, un polaco,
y escondió allá.
Y yo, saliendo,
voy a esconder
que al lado construyeron una casa
de tierra,
y el piso de tierra era 50 centímetros,
y yo me voy a mudar,
salgo de la casa,
me agarran
los ejércitos,
y me llevan
para Platzwuster.
Entro allá,
más o menos,
ya hay
entre 12 y 15 mil judíos.
¿Qué era Platzwuster?
Un terreno grande, vacío,
cercado con alambre.
Veo yo,
mi suegro,
mis cuñados,
Eva,
la señora,
hermano,
y muchos,
tal vez entre 12 y 15 mil,
pues ya no estaban conocidos,
y me llevan para allá adentro.
¿Qué puedo hacer yo?
Tal como esta casa, ¿sí?
En un lado, así,